all right guys
bang bang wow do i have a treat for you
guys today
webb is here thank you so much for doing
this my friend oh my honor man thanks
for having me
absolutely uh let's jump right in to uh
those who have seen the tweets you uh
you are the expert when it comes to uh
all things e-commerce media and
direct-to-consumer it seems like but uh
talk to us about your background
and kind of what you did before you
started 2 p.m
yeah uh so i've set my career mostly in
e-commerce
uh i would say my first big boy job was
um
marketing at rogue fitness um
one of the i i would say the nation's
preeminent direct to consumer fitness
manufacturer
uh learned a ton about customer
acquisition and
a lot of the components of the business
that you don't get to really see
in larger organizations and it's a big
company now really proud of what they've
done
left there went to mizzen and maine
co-founded that with kevin level
that's continuing to grow really excited
to see that company
exceed expectations and from there i
decided to not be an entrepreneur for a
while
so i work for a few folks i
was uh you know focused on e-commerce at
uncreate.com
and then i was director of e-commerce at
gear patrol
and it was at gear patrol when i focused
on starting 2pm
because frankly i think we were
beginning the election season around
then
and i wanted a place to go where we just
focused on the craft in the industry
and i i think i curated my first
newsletter for
12 subscribers and just sort of took it
from there
and uh you know i decided to go all in
gave myself about six weeks to start
generating revenue and
thank god it worked out i love that
um let's talk a little bit about uh
first the name
2 p.m it stands for two poly maths
what was the thought process behind the
name and then we can get into kind of
what you guys are doing today
yeah i think one of the interesting
things about the digital industry is
that the more
generalist you are and your approach to
education
obviously deep generalism is the the
goal um the more you can sort of see the
interconnectivity
you know the i want to call it neural
pathways between ideas and concepts and
industries and
i think that other industries solve your
industry's problems right so
if you're an e-commerce person then you
focus solely on
on retail and all that nonsense um
i think one of the things that you can
find is that it's usually the adjacent
industries or maybe the arts and
scientists
sciences excuse me that you you can sort
of rely upon to help you
[Music]
i don't know fill voids in your
strategies or
address issues that maybe you know
traditionalists wouldn't see
because they're focused solely on on
their craft and i think that's
sort of the goal with with 2pm to help
you build
new neural pathways between ideas yeah i
love that
and it feels to me like that's also a
very um
ever-expanding uh kind of mission right
there's always new things to learn about
there's always new things that you can
kind of get better at to help in this
in this journey so when you get started
uh you said you curated a newsletter at
first
talk us just through kind of the
evolution of the product
kind of from where you started to what
you guys are offering today
yeah uh listen i think i was
amateurish at the beginning uh hopefully
not too bad
i'm still growing as as a writer and as
a curator
um i read every single thing that i
curate
so i would say at the beginning i i
would i was probably rushed
um the first i would say 180
newsletters involved quite a bit of my
time and i put my heart into them
but they aren't close to the quality
that you're seeing today
um with you know with increased
subscription
and increased paid membership i'm able
to
add more the newsletters as far as um
original content uh original artwork and
things like that and so
there's a there's a vast difference
between even last year's newsletters and
this year's newsletters and
my goal you know with this type of model
is to continue to improve
you know we have a very lean team it's
me and maybe five or six contractors
they work really well i think they're
the top of their industries and
you know they they contract their time
to 2 p.m
and i couldn't do it without them but
the vast majority of this falls on my
shoulders and
it's that's something that's likely
never going to change
yeah and one of the things that uh when
i first started reading some of the work
that you guys have
is um you really have these kind of i'll
call them the intersection of three
ideas
uh direct to consumer e-commerce and
media
um there's those touch a lot of things
right so kind of they're very broad
terminology how do you think about
what you're covering right is that an
accurate depiction or do you kind of
think about it in a different way than
just
commerce media and direct consumer yeah
i think that the
sort of the you know the center of those
industries
are a leading indicator of
greater conversations elsewhere
if you look at retail data for instance
you can begin to sort of project
forecast
other industries right like by looking
at
the things that i was covering a year
ago i could say
hey this is going to happen to the
suburbs this is what's going to happen
to malls
you know these are the sociological
shifts that are that are occurring and
you can see that
just by studying where we spend our
money how we spend our money where we
spend our time and how we spend our time
well it just so happens that you know we
are an e-commerce economy or at least
we're becoming that
and if you are an indie industry
any industry in the world uh it's more
than likely that your industry will be
influenced by
you know these digital businesses in
some way shape or form
um so whereas e-commerce began as sort
of a niche study
i think it's becoming essentially the
new infrastructure for this for this
century um and i'm not trying to sound
self-important but i do think that
studying this stuff will help
people really understand other aspects
of our
uh i don't know our day-to-day lives and
maybe we're not considered
yeah it's really interesting this
morning i wrote um kind of about this uh
digital commerce trend and how that
leads to the financialization of
everything and i was excited to talk to
you because
uh i hadn't spent a lot of time thinking
about it and i feel like i'm talking to
the person who's probably spent the most
time talking about it uh
but but the way that i kind of came up
with the framework in my head was like
we started out with like simple things
right like buying books and then it
evolved to
everything from you can buy you know
groceries and electronics and kind of
all these items that i think are now
ingrained in people's heads and
associated with e-commerce but when you
really
pull back and look at like well what are
people buying online like carvana is a
multi-billion dollar business they're
selling used cars and you basically go
like a giant vending machine or open
doors doing
a real estate transactions where you can
buy and sell online
and so e-commerce is no longer like that
niche
industry of like let's sell little
things that we can put in a box and ship
to you
it's now pretty much every transaction
right so maybe talk a little bit about
how that evolution how you've seen it
happen
um and are there um i don't know kind of
guide post or or
um you know a box that you draw around
like what's e-commerce and
and what's not or does this eventually
just eat kind of every transaction in
the world
ends up being digital yeah i think one
of the most important things
is something that i tweet on occasion
and that's
listen d2c or direct to consumer can be
very insular
right i almost don't like that term
anymore because
people think about it in one specific
way think about it in
small businesses they use shopify
whatever
right like that's typically what people
think about when they think of those
that acronym i think of it in the terms
of a philosophy
right if you were studying the way that
those businesses operated five years ago
even three years ago you could see how
those same strategies and philosophies
would then be imparted upon
other industries whether it's telehealth
or real estate or car purchasing
whatever it is they're the same
principles
um and so i don't think that uh
ecommerce itself is insular anymore
i do think that every industry that we
know and touch
whether it's grocery education
um how we consume anything will be
affected by
these philosophies and that's why i
think they're so important to study
yeah and what are the terms that uh you
use often which i just absolutely love
is linear commerce explain what that is
and kind of gives maybe an example or
two as to uh
how people are implementing this in the
in the uh real world
yeah simply put it's the line where
media
meets commerce and for me
that is sort of the center of
a sustainable profitable long-term
viable business
because they can they can
influence demand and they can meet that
demand with supply
or they have supply and they can
manufacture that demand
whichever side of the industry they're
coming from so you're seeing
you know you're very familiar with
barstool that's a media company
that became a very commerce focused
brand
there are commerce companies that became
very good
at publishing video right
literature whatever it is i think one of
the examples that i gave
was actually from 1894 yesterday where i
explained that
the founders of michelin tire uh began
michelin ratings because they were
ginning up demand for tires
they knew that um if you
traveled more to heralded restaurants in
france
you would burn more rubber and buy more
tires there are there are
so many examples of that and that's the
core of linear commerce
taking two core functionalities two core
competencies
and making them the focus of your
business
so i think let's use barstool as an
example because i think many people
listening to this will at least have an
idea as to how that business works which
is basically you know it was a blog then
it kind of
moved into this social media realm now
there's a lot of video audio
uh type content uh but they also have a
hundred plus million dollar revenue
business
on that and obviously some of that is
advertising i think it's about thirty
percent thirty three percent
uh they've got a big merchandise
business um and then they've got
kind of uh other types of um
of revenue sources how do you look at a
business like that
in terms of merchandise is a very easy
type of um kind of linear commerce play
right of just okay we've got eyeballs
we're going to sell them t-shirts right
with kind of all kinds of branding
whatever
where can a business like that go right
and i think of it almost as like as they
mature as a business
the products that they sell become more
sophisticated and
uh not necessarily more complex but just
it's not as easy as like let's put a
print on a t-shirt and sell that through
drop shipping
so how do you see like the evolution of
these companies as they get more serious
about this idea of limited commerce
yeah i think the core of linear commerce
is loyalty right and so
especially from the media side when you
look at barcelona yeah they started off
pretty simply
with uh you know hats and t-shirts and
maybe polo shirts things like that but
what are they doing now they're they've
launched their first uh
digital app for um for betting they've
launched their own digital sports book
um that's a pretty complex product
they can do that and they can shoot to
number one in sports because they have
a ton of loyalty in their readership
for barstool probably the next sort of
evolution of that is the physical sports
book
right so when you see pin gaming
launch barstool you know
sports books and or restaurants with
sports book capabilities around the
country
market by market i'm not saying that
that's what they're going to do but it
wouldn't surprise me if they did it
a lot of that's going to be because of
the loyalty that they've built up over
the over the decade plus they've been in
business
and uh yeah you're going to see more
companies follow that
all that path especially if they have
the types of audiences that uh
that barcelo has yeah and it also feels
like uh because they've built
loyalty to barstool they've also built
loyalty to the individual
kind of uh celebrities or personalities
uh and then they almost have these like
inside jokes
uh with that audience and i think that
that kind of drives the loyalty but
i remember seeing in one of the decks i
think with uh penn national gaming
uh the idea that they may launch like uh
pizza shops right so physical locations
that sell pizza under the one bite name
they've got an app
that does that and you kind of start to
realize like wait a second every single
thing that keeps the consumer loyal like
the inside jokes the content like all
that
can be productized to some degree i
think that's kind of what you're getting
at with this linear commerce idea right
right right 100 i don't think there are
many businesses that have done it better
than them
i know that they're clearly a divisive
and sort of controversial company in
some ways
a lot of people would say that but i
think even
if you are incapable of appreciating
what they've done for their industry
objectively you have to see that they've
they've
succeeded in ways that other businesses
have not
and there are lessons that are
applicable most certainly
to uh to a number of businesses i really
wish that people would set aside
some of their distaste for their antics
and just study their business model
because
you know eric has done a wonderful job
like him or not dave is
like he has a midas touch when it comes
to productizing certain verticals and
it's just
it's been interesting to see yeah and
one of the ideas that
uh is fascinating to me is this idea
that businesses used to build their
product and then go find customers right
and now what might be happening is some
businesses actually go find the customer
first
and then build the products and so
barcelo's one example of that
one does that sound right to you and
kind of do you think that that will
become more popular over time
and then two is uh does it work if
somebody sets
out to do it right so one of the things
about like a bar stool or some of these
that are now
doing this is i don't know if they
necessarily like had some grand plan or
you know some master plan instead
they kind of just did the thing in the
short term that made the most sense to
kind of continue to drive revenue build
audience etc
and now as they kind of mature uh it
looks like oh my god look at this
amazing thing they spent 10 years
building an audience and now they've got
all these products
like how do you think about uh somebody
doing it intentionally versus it has to
be organic and kind of build over time
listen i think that intention can be
important i've always said this
i think one of my tweet patterns is i'll
i'll have like a short timeline and i'll
say 2010
people focused on building products and
then building demand around it
now people focus on building an audience
and then monetizing that audience
you have to have an element of sincerity
around what you're doing you can't say
hey let's
build an email list as big as we can and
acquire a bunch of email lists from
people that are no longer in business
and then
hopefully we can find a way to to build
a sustainable commerce business off of
that
yeah that might work in a in a very
short term but
um it takes a lot of originality and
sincerity behind it
you know intention is not bad but
i guarantee you when the barcelona folks
stall when they started this back in
whenever 2007 2006 i don't know what it
was
um they didn't say hey one day you know
we're gonna monetize this and turn it
into a 150 million dollar
million dollar your company that wasn't
the goal the goal was
how do we appease the people that we
care about most
how do we really reach this niche and
just give them everything that we got
um and hope for the best and what they
found was
that niche just a heck of a lot bigger
than they thought and that's the only
reason why it worked
right they were so sincere about um
what they wanted to accomplish early on
yeah how do companies think about this
if uh they don't have the benefit of
starting today
right so they've already built a product
and kind of they look more like a
traditional company
what do you see that the most successful
companies doing to kind of transition to
this linear commerce world are they just
going and trying to create as much
content as possible
or there are other things that they can
do to kind of navigate this transition
i think it's a really good question i
think you can sort of use tpm as sort of
a microcosm of this right now i mean
uh the first 180 letters at 2 p.m they
were free
and they were published in my spare time
after work typically
um before work and that was a goal i was
like i'm going to get to 180 letters i'm
probably going to stop
and i got to like 179 i'm like i sort of
want to continue this because
there are people that are reading this
that i would have never been able to
introduce myself to and that's just a
really cool resource to have
let's continue this i should probably
find a way to monetize it because i
can't
do this anymore in my spare time for
free
and that's when i decided to make the
pivot to wordpress and
i i think i pivoted from i forgot the
platform that i was originally using but
i moved to mailchimp and
i spent a little money on design you
know it was a big chunk of money
for me at the time and eventually it
became okay how do i productize
some how do i productize some of this so
i can make a living and
not have to work two jobs right now and
uh that's
that's sort of how that worked now it's
i think tpm has
five or six products so you know when i
get notifications
they're never the same it's there's six
ways essentially to transact on the site
um but at the core of everything that
i've done it's all been how do i serve
this particular industry that at the
time was very niche
i think what we're seeing is that the
e-commerce industry is
not as niche as we once thought
yeah and so when you thought about
monetizing
there's obviously a bunch of different
ways you could do that you could do
everything from
advertising in the newsletter you could
do subscriptions you could do affiliate
links you could do
kind of merchandise or commerce how did
you think about
um kind of sequentially rolling out
those five or six products from a
monetization standpoint
yeah i think originally it was just
traditional membership like hey
uh i need a percentage of you all to the
transact so that i can
like afford food from my daughters next
week you know
um and that that worked out and
thankfully it did and then
um i moved towards i really wanted to
maintain operational focus
so i listen i believe that the best
writing
is operator driven and you can't do that
unless you're actually in the thick of
it and so i was like okay
i should probably you know
consult companies and you know
have some skin in the game and help
build from the inside out
and without breaking any confidentiality
or anything like that
use the things that i'm seeing at scale
to shade my writing in ways right
to show that hey you know there's still
things that
i'm doing on a day-to-day basis that
when i do write about them
you know they're based in actual
doing and not just observation so that
was the impetus behind the consulting
and then
there's just smaller packages and a few
other things on the site that you can do
and
i'm always surprised whenever whenever
people transact but
so far it's so far so good yeah and one
of the things uh you tweeted recently
that i found really fascinating
is uh you basically were saying look if
i was to start a ddc brand today
i would go after product first then i'd
go for distribution and then i would
focus on brand
uh when people think of d2c i think this
goes back to the conversation around
like they have a specific type of
company in their mind right so maybe
like a casper
or whatever it is uh and they think of
like really
powerful brands or well-known brands uh
and then maybe it's something about
uh the product and then the distribution
and so in my head like that's kind of
the starting point for some people when
they hear d2c
another kind of data point on this is uh
yc is famous for saying you know first
time founders focus on product second
time founders
focus on distribution uh and so when i
saw kind of your order
um in terms of what you would focus on
it would surprise me a little bit maybe
talk through like
why product and distribution and then
brand uh kind of if you were to build a
dc company today
yeah listen i think that was a very
unique tweet for me i wouldn't normally
say something like that
but that was in response to that
bloomberg
uh blending report i don't know if you
saw that it was really really
interesting
um what was the report he was
essentially it was a great
opinion piece i forgot the gentleman's
name but he was essentially writing that
um a lot of these direct consumer brands
seem sort of idyllic and identical in
their approach to messaging their
approach to their marks
their actual physical marks and all that
stuff and uh
a lot of that is the result of the what
i call the ddc industrial complex
you know there's probably 10 or 15
agencies that
get paid really really well to produce
uh images and brands and messagings
and a narrative around the founders and
why they started the company and
everything like that and so
you're seeing the same adjectives and
the same sort of positioning
for every single brand and a lot of it
a lot of it is being sort of called out
because
not only are a lot of these brands doing
that um
and listen there are a few there are a
few exceptions in that article
uh i would like to cite that like the
sill was included in that article
whereas
she bootstrapped for the first five
years she probably didn't have any
business being in that article would be
fair
but the larger point was there is
sort of a homogeny about all of it and
couple that with the fact that there
have been so few exits
and so little liquidity outside of you
know a handful of founders
taking 10 million off the table here and
there which i
definitely disagree with um
and what you have is sort of a
frustration within the industry
the antidote to that uh the antidote to
that is essentially
building a product that people actually
like right
and so when i was tweeting that i was
talking about a lot of the brands that
actually
did achieve liquidity uh
events brands that did grow on profit
and cash flow
versus raising the five million dollars
first coming up with
the brand and the message then rolling
out the product and hoping for the best
there are a number of those companies
and so i cited you know jay's ice creams
in columbus ohio there's
siete foods in in austin san antonio i
believe
uh there's bulletproof you know there's
going back a little bit further there's
uh
gt dave and synergy right you know these
are
companies that are on the way to billion
dollar status and
they did it way differently than the
vast majority of direct direct to
consumer brands today
typically do it and they're seeing more
success so you have to ask yourselves
why and
my short answer is that they focused on
building a great product first
and getting those people to actually
like it the product developed the
audience
in ways yeah it's really really
interesting because
uh you know we're talking about d2c type
companies
right now but we've seen this uh with
other companies as well so whether it's
the nikola
uh kind of car company right or it's the
quibbes
of the world who go out they raise tons
of money and i think that you know
people who have been around a while
especially
from a venture capital perspective uh
red flag number one is you raise way too
much money and you don't even have a
product yet right
red flag number two is like you don't
have any of the venture capital firms
actually invested so they kind of all
passed and you went elsewhere for
capital
um and i think that like every once in a
while we have to almost have these to
remind everyone
of this focus on like the ultimate goal
here is to find that product market fit
it's not to raise as much capital as
possible so it's interesting that you
know
even though you see it in the d2c space
and it kind of feels like this like
homogeneous type
thing the mechanism is still happening
elsewhere as well right it's almost like
a sign of the times to some degree it
feels like
oh for sure i mean i think that you
raised a few interesting points
obviously uh with nicola it's
that's a great example of not having
anything to show for
a lot of money invested but you know
in a much lesser sense there are no
brands that are as egregious
nearly as egregious as what that
company's done but there are a lot of
brands that
don't really have a path to exit
optionality because they've raised a lot
of money
relative to their potential market cap
and
they they are not private equity fodder
anymore because of that
because of that cap table situation and
they will probably not be able to reach
sort of
um exit velocity because
they need paid marketing or whatever
mechanism is out there to to really sort
of gain a lot of traction within the
industry
it's just a really weird dance and i
think the only way to beat that dance
is to have a product that can put up
numbers
what i would say anywhere between one to
three million in the first five years
and annual revenue profitably
before they're really taking on growth
capital if that's sort of the dna of the
company i think that company actually
has a better shot of becoming a billion
dollar brand than
somebody coming out of the gates raising
20 to 50 million
yeah and talk a little bit about how
you're seeing founders uh
navigate to that point right so when
somebody hears kind of a million to
three million dollars there's certain
businesses where the
um capital needed to to start is very
low right literally just if you can
build
a piece of software then you're off to
the races uh some of these businesses
though there's physical products
involved there's some capital intensive
nature and so how do you see founders
kind of getting off the ground
to the point where it may make sense to
actually go out and raise kind of these
larger rounds
yeah listen i i know that nothing
happens in a vacuum
right i mean if you look at mizzen we
definitely raised the 250 000
friends and family round we we would
still consider ourselves bootstrappers
in ways because
you know we didn't pay ourselves for the
first two and a half years and trust me
was really painful
um but uh we we tried to build a
strategy around not needing to raise
more money
and we did and because we built a
strategy around
trying to not raise more money we were
probably more capable of raising money
in a reasonable fashion that put the
company in a decent long-term position
um i would say that uh listen
i think that for a lot of founders
especially coastal ones raising money is
pretty easy relative to the industry
and direct to consumer was hot
it's fallen off but it's come it's
coming back as e-commerce penetration
continues to rise and so
it's going to continue to be easier for
la new york san francisco boss and so on
and so forth to
to raise that 3 million dollar seed or
precede even you know
and i just don't think that that's the
route even if you are
in a capital intensive business um try
to do it without
the institutional capital try to do it
you know with people that
know you know you well and believe in
your vision
obviously not everyone has that rolodex
i i trust me i speak from experience
um we didn't have that rolodex the very
beginning it was very hard for us but
it can be done and you know to for
reference
that entire 250 000 capital expenditure
was focused on buying our first run
of first generation shirts from mizzen
which
you know sorry kevin i mean i can think
i think you can say this now because we
can look back on it fondly
but the first generation of shirts they
weren't great
so selling them was pretty difficult but
we found a way to do it
yeah and let's talk a little bit about
kind of this creator economy
um it's really interesting to me how uh
it's almost like creators are the new
small business
right and what we're seeing is uh take
the sub stack you know kind of
revolution if you will there's much
people leaving
uh and now they've got this ability to
uh kind of do it
you know one version of where you could
you really started with like this
membership
model do you see those people
trying to build out actual businesses or
is this just a
where writers want to get paid to write
right and what i keep going back to is
this idea of
is there a separation between kind of
people who want to build a business
and people who want to just create or
are we going to see kind of the rise
of the hybrid right the people who want
to create things but also
have the ambition and the skill set to
actually build businesses as like the
ceo as well
yeah listen i think that's sort of the
conundrum that i'm in right now right
it's like um i want to upm to be a media
company not a person
and so i've built strategies around that
with substack in particular obviously
you're very familiar with it
i think that the vast majority of the
the top users
are individuals they're building
their own creator pipelines they're not
necessarily
building media companies i think it's
hard
to build a media company on substance
obviously there are a few exceptions
and those exceptions might be growing in
the in the near future
but um but it's it's hard so i think
with
casey newton for instance today right
like you see him as a
as one heck of a journalist like that's
you will make a lot of money as an
individual journalist
um i'm i think it's different than
the alternative which is i think that i
forgot the name but the group from
deadspin that launched on substance a
few a few weeks ago
do you remember the name i don't but i
know who you're talking about so
i think there's 30 of them and they are
i think they is this defector
yes yes they so 20 000 something
subscriptions uh which is insane
so that's sort of the dichotomy right
there there's the individual
and then there's sort of the the
umbrella where
do you hear you hear a defector but you
don't notice well
i can't name a single journalist that's
actually writing for defector but it's a
very
uh valuable organization that could
potentially
believe substance and do its own thing
and have just just as much
success i think that's the difference
right but can you
can you build an audience can you build
a structure around employing the right
people
and can you port that audience elsewhere
on your own url
and with your own design with your own
logo work to build a media company
i think that's sort of like the the mark
that determines that yeah and we've
obviously seen this before with like the
buzzfeed and they came out with buzzfeed
products right and kind of put it
through
and one of my favorite examples uh and
the name's gonna escape me now
but uh they do the really in-depth um
product reviews like if there's a watch
that says you know it's 30 meters
kind of water resistant they literally
put it on and go 30 meters down in the
water and make sure that it uh
it does it um but those types of
organizations have found
multiple ways to monetize uh but they
have large staffs right
they're kind of well-funded in this
creator economy
we're almost seeing people start
businesses
from scratch with no funding in most
cases maybe there's some kind of
personal funding that they're you know
putting towards it
but but it really does feel like we're
getting back to this idea of like
the only people who are going to survive
and have the option or possibility of
thriving
or the people who find product market
fit right because they're going to use
the the
revenue to basically fuel anything else
they want to do is that directionally
correct do you think
it is i mean i think there are a number
of companies i'm not trying to sell
anyone short because i've seen it happen
myself there are a number of companies
that started small
and have quite a substantial footprint
on the industry i think an example is
probably
one of my stops i mean uncrate is
probably
a great example because you know i don't
know what the
what the payroll is but they they have
no more than 15 people
right now and if you compare them to
much much larger organizations with 60
or even 100 people
the output looks the same well that
company started with one person doing
one thing
right and it sort of scaled up from
there
so i'm not gonna i'm not gonna belittle
anyone that starts off as one person
because clearly that's the same way that
i started i just know that
to build an actual sort of
um to build brain equity i think we have
to focus more on
um inanimate brand and not the person
behind it
i think that's that's the key difference
in in in the creator economy today
yeah you've made um a number of
investments you
uh consult you um have been an advisor
to companies and
you've obviously worked at them talk a
little bit maybe about um
we spent talking about the brands and
kind of the companies what's some of the
infrastructure that you're seeing that's
enabling all this right so substack is
one that's kind of helping to accelerate
it
are there other companies that people
may or may not have heard about that you
kind of put in the infrastructure
category but you think will become
really important in the future
yeah listen i'm a huge fan of memberfold
they've been my engine for quite some
time
uh there's alternative platforms for
publishing i think
i think ghost is popping up uh you know
traditionally clapio is an alternative
though it's typically focused on b2b
um i think that shopify is on to
something
i've i've gotten sort of glued in from a
few of their folks that
they're coming up with solutions for the
creator economy themselves
um i think it's a very fascinating time
and
uh i don't know if you're familiar with
lee jen from a16z
she talks about this quite a bit there's
a host of sas platforms that are focused
on answering this question
especially as uh the american electorate
continues and the american consumer
therefore
continues to sort of fracture right like
everyone's moving in their own
directions
i think the media and commerce will
reflect that
yeah it's really interesting as well
because it feels like
while we're talking about this vertical
kind of integration between
content brand products etc for
for the businesses the infrastructure
providers have actually
stayed uh pretty independent meaning
that
um you know if you look at amazon amazon
basically helps you sell things but also
they sell their own things and kind of
compete with you
um substance for example doesn't have
their own publications also on substance
right or
shopify to my knowledge doesn't sell
products as well as kind of arm the
rebels of other people
uh does that change over time like do
you see a world where the infrastructure
providers start to eat more and more of
the stack and actually compete with the
people that they're helping to some
degree
i do um i think
substance will become its own media
company
i think eventually they're going to
acquire some of the top performers and
sort of
build a strategy around their own direct
brand of media i don't know what that
focus will be on but
maybe it's maybe it's local news
whatever i think they're going to focus
on that
i think eventually shopify will focus on
becoming a marketplace
and competing head on with amazon they
have access to
hundreds of brands that will never work
with amazon and i think that that's a
competitive advantage that they have yet
to realize
it's you know going back to the original
comments on linear commerce it's
incumbent upon a lot of these platforms
to eventually compete with the people
that are using the platforms i think
that's natural
the margins are probably higher if they
do that and it's it's a lot more
long-term viable if they are building
those strategies around
being their own supply and their own
demand
and as you think through uh how a lot of
this is financed um there's been a bunch
of attention
lately on um you know companies like
pipe and others that
uh are finding ways to let's say uh
have more advantageous capital given to
sas companies with reoccurring revenue
right
i don't think we've seen too much yet
and you know more than i do in terms of
either d to c companies or kind of the
creator class around
financing in a non-dilutive way any
thoughts there as like how that part of
the industry may evolve to help some of
these people access capital
but still kind of remain true to the way
they want to build the companies
well uh i haven't heard much with
regards to
non-dilutive capital outside of the
advances that stop
that substance i guess continues to
provide a few top performers
eventually there will probably be
mechanisms around that you know maybe
i forgot the name of the uh the provider
out of
toronto they provide
clear bank yes thank you so much you're
the man
uh i just have a bunch of company names
floating around in my head so
that was so good thank you so much
because it completely slipped my mind
but yeah
i could see them focusing on something
like that for creators
it makes sense uh there are certainly a
few things that you can invest in in the
first
two to six months of doing business that
can help you to drive
more revenue moving forward and frankly
for people like me i've done everything
organically so far
you know a conversation with clearbank
is probably
not trying to plug them but a
conversation with someone like clearbank
it probably
could probably be advantageous for me
because you know at some point i will
probably have to pursue
paid marketing and paid acquisition and
it's it will probably be smarter for my
business to do that
on top of everything else than i'm doing
and you know
uh there are a host of of
creator newsletters creator-based
newsletters that can
benefit the same yeah what's really
interesting about it too
is um i think a lot of people have
thought about sas recurring revenue
right so i built a software platform you
pay me for you get to use it you know
on kind of a daily basis or weekly basis
uh
is there a difference in the recurring
revenue of a substack or
you know one of these other platforms um
you got a different type of customer in
many cases uh the price points may be
different but
from a mechanism standpoint it's still
recurring revenue right i think there's
a slight difference and i think i think
for me
it's one that i actually focus on um you
know
i think the goal is to make your
platform a resource
just like sas is typically focused on
being a resource for users
and that resource could provide a lot of
lock-in
for your for your customers um you know
lowering churn boosting retention and
all that
i could see investors focusing on
newsletters that become
their own resources for us it's you know
we focused a lot on the databases
we were trying to quantify the private
markets you know i
jeff richards is one of my mentors out
at gg capital and i tell him all the
time like
i i'm trying to build private markets
bloomberg which i know sounds
incredibly ostentatious but
one of my goals is to help investors say
hey these are the direct consumer brands
that are
probably most likely to have some
semblance of exit optionality
based on these metrics and we are
improving those metrics
by the month so that resource that i
that i could see
investors being really interested in
funding absolutely
the last thing i want to talk about
before we go to the rapid fire to finish
this
is this idea of membership right so
you've done a fantastic job i think of
kind of really directing the uh the
branding the conversation around
membership and not so much uh a
transactional relationship or just like
hey you're a subscriber
right talk about kind of one what your
thought process is behind
membership versus maybe subscribers uh
and some of the advantages or even maybe
disadvantages to
pursuing a strategy that's built on
membership more than anything else
uh well i think that's really really
important to note membership is
is the most important thing that you can
focus on uh subscribers to me
are are are flimsy they're passing
they can certainly be loyal but most
most often you know if
if i think that subscribers as a class
are typically
less engaged with your product
members are people that you have a
two-way relationship with
so they can email you you can help them
solve problems
if you had a room full of members the
members would feel like they are around
like-minded valuable people
they're like a cohort and that's the way
that i see my members
that's why i host our dinners to try to
get as many of them in the room together
as possible obviously code would put a
you know put a hold on that for a little
bit but we're kicking that off again
pretty soon
here in the city here in new york and um
i'm really excited for that i think
those are sort of the elements that can
help
uh above and beyond traditional
subscribers build a long-term strategy
around members that stick with you
users that stick with you yeah i think
it's jared dicker who talks a lot about
like membership basically is the loyalty
right going back to kind of where we
started the conversation and
um it not only uh is a
very aspirational thing right but it
also starts to bleed into
identity and so if you can do it the
right way that identity um
you know people don't want to change
their identity very often right
and that's right that's a really
interesting way to look at it
absolutely i mean jared is on to
something i love the way that he thinks
he's he's he's
right on when it comes to the the
delineation between the two
i think they often get conflated and
they're not the same at all
um to have a subscriber is wonderful i
mean that's what we're all
seeking right anyone in this economy
that's more focused on
but but you know i think what's really
going to continue your business and
allow you to
build to build on in the long term those
are members and
they're they're paying you for the
future of your company not what exists
right now
absolutely uh before we get into the
rapid fire where can people find you on
the internet or find out more about 2pm
yeah so i'm just at web at web on
twitter
um you can find me on linkedin just
websmith um obviously
my pride and joy my my non-human baby
is uh 2pml.com or 2pm.inc
either one um and yeah i think that
that's where you will uh
enjoy your time getting at web on
twitter a three-letter
twitter handle means that uh you either
know magic or you were early which one
is it
i i i got lucky i um long story short
i i ended up buying the handle in 2010
from this british aristocrat that was
sitting on it
and uh he wanted like 72 thousand
dollars for it
and i was not in a position at all to
pay even a fraction of that and so i
paid him an installment it's like 3 000
bucks
and he handed it over to me and i was
like man this is this is really
important
and he's like okay fine after six months
of delineation so
uh yeah that's that's how it works
that's an amazing story and
the fact that he's an aristocrat makes
it even better oh yeah
yeah he said i think he he lived in a
castle or something
i see a photo one day i don't know if
he's being serious but like man
i don't know what money you're making
but that's definitely not what's
happening in austin
texas right now yeah well what's even
better is like
to sell a twitter handle for 72 thousand
dollars is like only somebody who lives
in a castle would pretty big
no uh i have like a few pennies please
help me
i love it uh what is i asking two
questions to everybody uh what is the
most important book that you've ever
read
oof shoe dog why
i don't think there are many books that
show you the the entire path
from zero to one like that book um just
the pain
the the repetitiveness of of dismay
and destruction how they bounce back
from a time time of time
as someone that's really focused on
retail and brands that book was really
that book was really important for me to
read and um
it's one that's like etched in my memory
i love that answer
uh second one's more fun aliens believer
or non-believer
i do tend to believe that we get a lot
of our technology from
foreign planets okay hold on no one's
ever said that before explain
where uh where are we getting this
technology listen uh
i know that we have some wonderful
scientists on the face of the planet
you know uh thank you to the germans and
the russians for helping us you know
pioneer the space age but i think that
we've just seen
some drastic booms in technology over
the last 200 300 years that
a logical person would say is probably
inspired from elsewhere i don't know
i mean i never really think about it so
this is probably gonna be held against
me but
i think it's logical you know you can't
be alone right
yeah i tend to agree with you that we're
definitely not alone i don't know about
getting technology from elsewhere but
uh the the most fascinating story i've
heard on the alien front
is uh this guy bob lazar yeah
yeah well he and he's more of the belief
of like we have technology here that we
can't explain and it came from somewhere
else
right so yeah it's down the right path
uh
to wrap this up you could ask me one
question what's the one question you got
for me
ooh how do you stay so productive
you're really knocking these out yeah i
i
said it yesterday on uh onsite's podcast
uh between yesterday and today
uh i'll have recorded eight podcasts
i've done the newsletter each day
uh the daily youtube show uh i signed a
term sheet for an investment yesterday
like
yeah cranking um and uh
it just comes down to one really
enjoying
doing this like getting to spend an hour
and a half with you
as i was like woke up this was like yes
like let's do it all right
so just excited to kind of learn from
from people who spend a lot of time
thinking about specific things
uh the second part i think is just uh
being really efficient with your day
so if you look um kind of you know my
day is scheduled to the minute
kind of all the way through um and then
also i think there's this element of
uh focusing on the micro but
understanding the impact it has on the
macro
of like i always use the example nick
saban
talks about you know just do your job on
this play and every offensive play is
dropped to be a touchdown
and the only reason why we didn't score
a touchdown is because someone messed up
their job
right and so uh if you kind of just
think of like okay what's my job it's
like do the same thing
every day for five plus years and then
like then you get to enjoy the
the you know kind of benefits of that
yeah so
i really like you said about every
offensive play being drawn up to score a
touchdown that that's
pretty impactful um but it all comes
down to execution right
it's uh when i started to think about is
years ago
a football coach told me this and uh i
was like
i never thought about that like
literally every play is a touchdown on
the board
right uh right and what you realize is
like there's both internal and external
factors that can prevent it
so you know the center may snap the ball
and then miss the guy in front of him uh
on the block he's supposed to make but
is it because
he messed up right like he didn't take
the right steps or do what he's supposed
to do
or is it just that the player across the
you know the line
is a better player and just anticipated
something like it so it's not always
kind of
self-imposed or kind of self-inflicted
wounds uh it can be external forces
but if you just know look every place a
touchdown and i'm going to do my job and
if everyone else does their job we're
going to score
it's a pretty good way to look at light
friend pretty profound man pretty
profound
that's why nick saban has a bunch of
national championships and you and i are
sitting here on
the internet wishing that uh our college
football teams were as good as alabama
fair enough fair enough awesome listen
thank you so much for uh for taking the
time to do this i think people are going
to learn a ton from you today
thank you i highly suggest everyone go
check out 2pm
or find web at web on twitter and we
will definitely have to do this again in
the future
sounds good sir talk to you soon